Get it. Uh, so yeah,
God, that pizza gate thing is so funny. My, my Netflix specials out,
everybody go check it out. Uh, watch this special, our watch this, uh,
speaking of Netflix, I watched this show, uh,
because I was watching breaking bad and just needed a break. You know,
me and wife watch him breaking bad. I needed a break because it's too,
it's just too intense. And we were like, let's retire,
breaking bad. And let's watch doomsday preppers. Now she wanted to go to sleep.
It me off. All good.
I want it to stay awake and watch doomsday preppers to kind of cancel out the
breaking bad. Now, does it me off? Yes. Is it okay? Sure. It's fine.
Somebody has got to get up at 6:00 AM and feed my baby,
but I watched doomsday preppers and uh,
these people are like the people that think that pizza gate is real.
I watched two episodes because that's how I do when some on Netflix,
sometimes I'll watch two episodes.
I don't watch three or four unless it's like some real hot,
but sometimes I like to test out. I like to dip my toes in the Netflix water.
You know what I mean? I like to do that.
If something's called doomsday preppers, you've got them, right.
I'm not gonna watch the whole thing, but I'm going to dip my toe in it.
Because I'm a curious George. Okay.
And if you have a problem with that, then get to step in. Um,
these people are nuts though. How about that? It's actually a really good,
well put together show. Um,
these guys talk about, uh,
these guys talk about the world.
Like they're scared of like either terrorist attacks, uh,
one guy's in a mobile home and he just drives everywhere and he
drives everywhere and he's got like satellite hooked up, but he could,
he blogs from a. I forget what his name is, but he's online and.
He's got a podcast that he does from his mobile home and he just keeps driving
dude. And he's got like a crossbow in guns just in case.
And he sets up the security cameras so he can see heat, heat coming to it.
It's like, and he's just like, look, man, if a terrorist attack Cummins,
I'm going to be on. I'm going to be on the road.
I'm I'm going to drive to where it's safe. And they're like, well,
what about gas? And he's like, well,
that's my only thing that I'm worried about.
I have like a year's worth of supplies eating wise in my, in my trunk here.
And he's got like that he needs to plant and like dried food that he needs to
add water to. And he makes his own water and.
He makes everything and it's just so insane. And I'm just like, dude,
how are you running from terrorism every day of your life?
Not sure if something's going to happen in the meantime,
you're not living your life. Like dude, if terrorists are going to.
Get me, he's like, he's like, cause you know how I,
when he's like me stay mobile, that's how I win. And I go like this out.
Loud to wifi. I say he lost already. And she goes,
and I'm more.
What got for watching doomsday preppers?
Excuse me. Doomsday. Preppers is on,
you know, she goes like this a lot when we're watching TV,
it's too loud and I'm just like for whoa, dude.
Could you just turn it lower for what.
I get. Hey, yes.
Um.
Yeah. Do you guys enjoy your quarantine to Easter? Did you do that?
Another guy was on duty. Another guy was on doomsday, preppers and he was, uh,
underground.
Oh, what about the sun?
Hey dude. Are you a gopher?
What about a sun? What about the sun? Another guy was on,
what was the other guy? There was another guy that was, oh, he was just,
he had a self-sustainable.
He's like I don't have any more cash. He's like, I don't have money. I barely,
I don't have any bills though. The only thing I have bills on is his cell.
Phone and I have enough money to cover my cell phone for a few years.
And he was like, and I don't even need to, you know,
if a cell phone who cares if I have a cell phone tonight and his wife was like,
yeah, let's go practice shooting things in the yard. And he was like, okay.
And they get, he got.
The only time they ever gonna use it is during this show doomsday preppers.
Also, he was like, that's the thing.
If invaders come to find my place because my place is really good,
then I could ward them off with these guns.
And we've got places in my yard that we have coolers of of food
and bullets and guns and sniper rifles. And he was like, so we're good.
And I'm like, but what about the show?
But what about how everyone's going to see where you live now?
Because it's on Netflix and everybody's watching Netflix.
Watch my special it's streaming now, no pain.
But yeah, that's like that whole thing when it was when it's like.
When it's like, when they show like the movies or not the movies, sorry,
the docu-series is where it's like about gang life.
Real deal or whatever. They, all the titles are the same.
It's like gang life blood for glory, gang life,
real deal streets, the streets of LA gang life bloods versus Crips,
the lifestyle, blood, blood, blood in blood out gang left gang,
gang, gang, and gang. And with the gang or sins, you know,
it's all named the same. And uh,
and then you get the guy that was like, this.
Was a top done of the couple of the game of the Crips from 1980 to
1995. And he was just like, yeah, man. You know,
we had to kill mother just for looking at us the wrong way, man.
We killed about three, four just looking at us wrong way.
We killed by three more, four looking at us the wrong way.
And we killed much more than that for who do one much more than that.
If you know what I mean, and I'm just at home home, like.
Hey, get him.
This is TV. Are you confessing on video tape?
Get him.
Cops watching what cops are at home. And just.
Like, it. I'm off duty. I ain't watch it. And I'm not going to get him.
Where am I going? But in a Jacksonville, because that's where all crimes happen.
If a crime didn't happen in Jacksonville, guess what didn't happen?
That's my whole motto. That's how I'm going to run for mayor of Los Angeles.
If a crime didn't happen in Jacksonville, it didn't happen.
Mayor of Jacksonville, Jacksonville sucks. Anyway, uh.
Ah, um, doesn't.
Suck, dude. I've had some awesome shows in Jacksonville. I'm just playing dude,
ladies and ladies in on love you, I'm playing. I'm playing on. Love you. Um,